et qu'en est il maintenant de la
question de l'autonomie
ça c'est très intéressant c'est
probablement le point fort de ce
smartphone vous avez regardé ce que g
callen nazis cinéma spectacle vous avez
vu huawei et smart 2019
j'ai là deux boîtes de deux smartphones
de ce début d'année
c'est un nouveau modèle de huawei c'est
le ps marc 2019 qui vient succéder au p
smart
je vous le donne dans le mille 2018
smartphone plutôt cool alors smartphone
assez intéressant parce que c'est très
rigolo
il ya quelques années quand on parlait à
différentes personnes vous vos amis
peut-être plaint de maux prendre le
moment aussi huawei tout le monde
faisait ou ah ouais c'est quoi vos ouest
huawei et au final personne connaissent
et huawei ou et royal et pas forcément
ceux qui connaissent en tout cas une
bonne image de marque
aujourd'hui on vous parle de hawaï a
fait on va rouler fait ouvriers ouais
ouais ouais mais devint propre et 20 pro
pour le plus haut de gamme et plein
d'autres modèles de la marque
alors c'est très intéressant parce que
huawei gagne des positions énormes
huawei a détrôné apple ou wade veut peut
et veut devenir le numéro un mondial
alors c'est très clairement pas avec le
paceman 2019 qui vont changer a
révolutionné un peu le monde par contre
ça rajoute une bière à leurs édifices
sapin en tout cas de rafraîchir la gamme
dupe et smart de l'année dernière un
modèle qui va se positionner directement
face de leur propre marque de leur
marque six en tout cas qui est aux
normes pense notamment au nord 8x au
nord 17 ans c'est vraiment intéressant
se paie smart 2019 mais vous le
détailler quelques instants c'est pas le
smartphone de l'année c'est pas le
nouveau flagship qu'on attend c'est pas
du tout ça on est sur un smartphone
entrée milieu de gamme qui par contre
fait quelques promesses elle les tient
ça c'est cool que vous expliquer et qui
est pour moi un excellent rapport
qualité prix
début mi 2010 9 fin 2019 les choses
auront évolué donc il sera plus
forcément d'actualité mais pour ce début
d'année
je dirais jusqu'à juillet 2010 9 500 en
tout cas être un excellent produit je
voulais pas ça voilà les bêtes
on a ici les deux modèles de huawei paix
smart 2019 alors deux modèles jouent
moins que dos sac intéressant vous avez
deux couleurs vous avez le rova blue qui
est ce dégradé bleu un peu violine vous
le voyez tout de suite on recadre
immédiatement le le point négatif de ces
smartphones sont vraiment grosses traces
de doigts il prend beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup les traces de doigts vous avez
un de plastique qui par contre c'est
vraiment son effet donc vous le mettez
derrière une protection transparente
il est super bowl sera bien son effet
par contre il tout de suite prendre les
traces de doigts les petites rayures et
ça ça va être en tous cas le
l'inconvénient majeur 7 face à l'arrière
à côté de ça il est très joli et à vous
laver dans la couleur midnight black
pareil hyper élégant très sympa avec un
petit dégrader très léger là dessus il
est vraiment excellent boulot qui a été
fait par envoi web en tout cas je suis
très fan de de l'aspect arrière de ses
téléphones l'aspect avant et ce qui est
très intéressant et qui est très sympa
c'est qu'on voit qu'au final sera face
avant on a un design qui est assez
proche de ce qu'on a enfin 2018 petite
encoche goutte d'eau très léger haut
parleurs ici comment on peut retrouver
notamment sur le web + 6 t sur l'europe
aux airs x17 pro tout petit bordure ça
c'est cool menton qui est très très faim
un design qui est vraiment très sympa
sur le côté petit bouton de volume
bouton pour l'allumer pour l'éteindre
vous avez un haut parleur mono micro usb
prise jack sur le côté ici absolument
rien et là vous avez votre tiroir de
cartes sim pour insérer soit denanot sim
soit une nano sim et une carte micro sd
je vous l'expliqué ça dans quelques
instants
donc ça c'est plutôt cool je vais vous
montrer très rapidement à l'intérieur de
la boîte parce que ça peut être
intéressant bon il n'y a pas grand chose
de révolutionnaire
ce n'est pas comme de protection j'ai
ici un bloc de charge classique
j'ai ici mon câble
d'alimentation et j'ai ici des petits
écouteurs c'est pas folichon folichon
par contre ça marche bien c'est standard
c'est efficace c'est beau pratique voilà
la boîte elle est pas terrible non plus
on est sur un basique on est sur un
smartphone entrée et milieu de gamme
donc de ce point de vue là forcément ils
ont pas fait des efforts ce packaging
complètement ouf
par contre le smartphone en lui-même est
franchement intéressant la première
chose c'est quand on prend en main et on
se rend compte extrêmement rapidement
c'est un smartphone qui est hyper léger
ça c'est franchement intéressant parce
que il ya quelques smartphones il pèse
un peu leur poids celui-là a contrario
par rapport aux pixels 3 par exemple
pour faire de la pub pour google mais
c'est trois utilise en ce moment je
trouve franchement hyper léger fait 160
g
on le sent pas particulièrement ça c'est
bien la prise en main c'est pareil est
vraiment bien je sais pas des masses
énormes
néanmoins on trouve très facilement le
capteur d'empreintes digitales à
l'arrière il se positionne très
facilement dans la main donc le format
est parfait le poids est aussi un sacré
avantage donc ça c'est très intéressant
entre pointe alain donzeaud ce
smartphone c'est son grand écran vous
avez une dalle lcd 6,21 pouces 2340 par
1080 pixels c'est du full hd plus c'est
une excellente résolution avec un ratio
19,5 9e écran que je trouve assez
lumineux mais lorsque vous le mettez en
extérieur ça va c'est plutôt pas mal
vous arriverez toujours à vous en sortir
par contre il a un petit inconvénient il
tire légèrement semble heures j'ai mis
un fond rouge pour qu'on puisse s'en
rendre compte mais je sais pas si vous
le voyez directement à l'entrée être
colorimétrique l'avenir un petit peu
influencé tout ça mais il tire quand
même un petit peu sur le bleu on le voit
sur les les parties blanches alors par
contre vous pouvez très très très
facilement venir le corriger vous allez
dans vos paramètres vous allez dans
affichage et vous allez dans mode et
température de couleur et l'a ensuite
vous pouvez venir modifier vos couleurs
chaudes froides
vous faites ce que vous voulez vous
pouvez venir paramétré par vous même ça
ne vous aura pas échappé on a sept
petites encoches sur l'eau alors les
encoches vont être amenées à disparaître
si vous ne l'aimez pas vous allez une
fois de plus dans vos paramètres dans
vos paramètres d'affichage dont plus de
paramètres d'affichage dancosse et vous
pouvez complètement venir à la cacher
donc vous n'aurez plus cet aspect
encoches vous aurez juste vos petites
informations notification sur le haut
c'est au choix personnellement low cost
goutte d'eau ça me dérange absolument
pas
je préfère la garder à la limite je
trouve que c'est pas mal ça grandit
quand même légèrement l'écran qui dit
grand écran 10 côté plus immersif pour
le multimédia ça c'est un peu aussi très
intéressant notamment pour le visionnage
de vidéos et pour le jeu vidéo parce que
ce smartphone dans cette catégorie de
prix je vous le dirai tout à l'heure au
niveau de son prix il se destine
forcément un public assez jeune
il rentre en concurrence avec les
propres modèles de la gamme au nord qui
se destine à un public jeune et ça c'est
intéressant à voir parce que quelle est
la consommation principal d'un public
plus jeune c'est effectivement le
multimédia les jeux vidéo l'appareil
photo avec les réseaux sociaux on va se
concentrer pour l'instant sur la partie
jeux vidéo et multimédia pour venir
visionner des vidéos directement sur
youtube sur ce que voulaient d'ailleurs
ici ça rame la connexion ram c'est
pénible c'est très très facile
effectivement on peut venir nous mais
alors vu le ratio de l'écran voyez les
grandes banques sur le côté vous venez
de vous mais tout de suite ça bien
énormément zoomer dans l'image bon voilà
ça doit être bien ça peut être pas bien
c'est peut être un petit peu embêtant là
tout de suite
la résolution est pas terrible à cause
de la bande passante ça c'est un peu le
point négatif ici néanmoins pour du
multimédia ce genre d'écran ne me pose
pas de problème
il ya un point négatif là dessus c'est
l'audio le son est vraiment beaucoup
trop médium il fait mal aux oreilles
il est très criard ça fait quand même
relativement mal aux oreilles
le spectre est pas terrible ça c'est
vraiment le gros point négatif je dirai
pas ce que vous avez un seul
haut-parleur qui situe ici ce haut
parleur il vous sort un son qui est
uniquement très très très médium pas de
spectre sur les graves
franchement gouvernement ça pique un peu
les oreilles par contre point positif ce
smartphone à une prise jack
ce qui fait que si vous voulez pas
écouter du son comme ça que vous voulez
pas vous faire mal aux oreilles vous
prenez votre casque que vous positionner
sur votre tête jusque là je bosse que je
ne vous apprends absolument rien c'est
cool vous éviter de faire des noeuds si
vous faites des ne c'est pas grave
notamment pour le test à présent aucun
problème je prends je pose
j'allume jeu mes lectures et là
normalement
la magie opère alors tout de suite au
casque le spectre audio et franchement
mieux beaucoup plus respectés vous avez
un son qui est de bien meilleure qualité
donc ça c'est franchement intéressant
maintenant vous avez pas énormément de
puissance il manque un petit peu de jus
alors je n'ai un grand bémol quand je
dis ça parce qu'une fois de plus et je
dis à chaque fois je sensibilise
vachement fait très attention ne mettait
pas le son trop fort directement avec
votre casque évitez de vous rendre fou
ou sourde attention fait vraiment gaza
mais voilà ça peut aussi être un point
de regret il manque un peu de puissance
avec le casque et lorsque vous l'écoutez
s'encastre le haut parleur audio
développe trop de médium très clairement
c'est pas un smartphone c'est pour
écouter la musique bon à côté de ça pour
jouer un peu et bgc plutôt fluide mise à
part le fait qu'ils sont en train de me
faire trucider que j'arrive pas à
l'entrée dans les maisons et que je suis
assez mauvais sinon ça marche bien
impossible de rentrer à vous amuser pas
à mettre des performances complètement
hallucinante dessus parce que ça ne
marchera pas par contre la chanteraine
crever apg tant pis bye bye bisou à ciao
mais bon voyez pour un jeu en tout cas
même comme pib g ça marche ça c'est cool
biz ou au revoir parce que même si ce
smartphone est pas complètement ouf en
termes de performances il tourne avec un
kirin 710 couple est à 3 giga de ram une
config qu'on connaît déjà chez huawei
honor qui est prouvée qui marche bien
avec une optimisation logiciel c'est à
dire le gpu turmo ça vous donne un
smartphone qui fonctionnera parfaitement
bien pour trois quarts des usages voir
un petit peu plus donc pour jouer à des
jeux pas trop gourmands
ça fonctionne pour les réseaux sociaux
c'est largement suffisant pour écouter
de la musique pour regarder les vidéos
pour tout ce que vous voulez c'est a
parfaitement bien
néanmoins si vous voulez utiliser des
jeux qui vont être plus gourmand qui
vont vous demander en tout cas d'aller
un peu plus loin en terme de performance
il se peut qu'à un moment on vous soyez
un peu limité mais ça concerne très peu
de jeu très peu d'usagers donc c'est pas
une bête de puissance c'est pas le
smartphone qui va vous offrir le plus de
fluidité mais en attendant avec ça vous
n'êtes pas une rencontre tranquille
autre point qui est intéressant c'est le
stockage alors vous avez 64 giga de
stockage initiale que vous pouvez
augmenter jusqu'à 512 giga grâce à une
carte micro sd alors il faut faire votre
choix parce que vous avez la possibilité
d'avoir soit 1 catane aussi mais plus
une carte micro sd soit la possibilité
d'avoir deux cartes nano sim pour avoir
de ligne de téléphone voilà ça il faut
choisir ça vous voir au niveau du
benchmark vous vous en douterez c'est
pas un truc de ouf avec un résultat sur
en tout ou deux
131 1332 ce qui le classe pas du tout en
tête des smartphones en tout cas à les
plus performants par contre comme je
vous le disais pour en faire ce que vous
voulez pour des usages un peu standard
vous aura absolument aucun problème vous
serez pas du tout déçu et qu'en est il
maintenant de la question de l'autonomie
ça c'est très intéressant c'est
probablement le point fort de ce
smartphone
vous avez juste vous vous réveillez en
tout cas une batterie de trois mille
quatre cent millions terreur optimisée
grâce au gpu turbo d'un point de vue
logiciel est une combinaison kirin 710
mhz qui sait pas plus performants gpu
turbo os qui est optimisé autour de
cette batterie de trois mille quatre
cent millions terreur donc au final ça
vous donne quoi ces chiffres cette
configuration ça vous permet de
l'utiliser au max jusqu'à deux jours
alors jusqu'à deux jours franchement
comme pas être sauvage vous êtes
tranquille vous l'utilisez up à produire
vous l'utilisez pour des jeux un petit
peu quelques uns sociaux des emails des
coups de fil sms vous bourriner pas si
vous y allez un peu plus fort un jour et
demi si vous êtes carrément sauvage un
jour attention vous n'avez pas de
recharge rapide
il n'ya pas non plus de recharge sans
fil là dessus c'est un smartphone que
vous aller recharger en un peu plus de
deux heures alors bon si vous leur
charge et le soir ou la nuit
absolument aucun problème si par contre
la journée vous avez besoin de recharger
parce que vous êtes un petit peu trop
tiré sur la corde que vous manquez de
jeu il faut prévoir du temps
si vous avez juste dix minutes devant
vous vous n'allez pas lui mettre une
grosse recherche ça vous permettra de
vous sauver la vie pour quelques coups
de fil quelques sadness mais vous irez
pas très loin avec au delà de sa cote et
déverrouillage vous avez votre capteur
d'empreintes digitales à l'arrière ou
alors vous avez fait bloc avec votre
caméra à l'avant alors le capteur
d'empreintes digitales fonctionne
merveilleusement bien ça déverrouille
très rapidement ça c'est franchement un
grand plaisir c'est prouvé donc il ya
rien de nouveau là dessus et faith and
locke est assez efficace aussi aux
genevez cale un peu
j'appuie et voyez idée verrouille tout
de suite hyper connais ma tête c'est
franchement hyper rapide ça c'est très
agréable aussi l'ol est assez connue
très standard cee hui 9.0 qui est posée
directement sur un android 9 bein ça
marche ça va mais y avoir quelques
options assez intéressante notamment la
navigation par gestes pour ce faire il
vous suffit d'aller dans vos paramètres
vous allez dans système navigation
system et là vous choisissez les gestes
navigation à trois touches de navigation
par ce dimanche quoi faire
navigation par gestes c'est pratique
c'est rapide c'est beau ça marche bien
alors après vous avez plein plein plein
de paramètres et notamment la fameuse
question d'équilibré digital qui est une
notion très importante où vous allez
vraiment pouvoir savoir combien de temps
vous passez sur vos applications faire
attention bloqué à certains moments
lorsque vous allez trop enfin ça c'est
intéressant
aude po qui hyper intéressant c'est la
question de la photo vidéo parce que
huawei l'année dernière a littéralement
explosé pour peut le dire en ces termes
là par rapport à la photo vidéo à sempé
smart sur le p 20 euros et sur le mail
20 euros c'est pas là dessus qu'ils vont
vous bluffer en termes de photos vidéos
mais comme ils ont un vrai savoir faire
on peut se demander si derrière avec la
caméra du p smart donné 19
ils ont continué un petit peu dans cette
lignée là alors pour moi c'est un
photophone pas mal c'est pas mal le
résultat est pas mal vous avez un
capteur principal de 13 mégapixels avec
l'ouverture de f 1.8 vous avez un second
capteur de 2 mégapixels qui va être là
pour le mode portrait pour laisser bokit
réclament pas plus pas moins vous n'avez
pas de stabilisation lorsque vous allez
venir filmer en vidéo ça peut être un
peu dommage le résultat photo vidéo pris
directement avec l'appareil arrière et
panale la saturation n'est pas exagéré
c'est pas hyper contrat s'est néanmoins
je trouve que le rendu est à sellette le
rendu est très propre et ça c'est assez
intéressant
en plus de ça vous avez de la
reconnaissance de scène 22 catégories
différentes et cinq cents scénarios
différents
ce qui est très intéressant ça va être
une optimisation de la colorimétrie une
optimisation de l'image en fonction de
ce que vous allez prendre en photo on va
pas avoir même rendu si vous allez
prendre une fleur une nature morte en un
chien de la nourriture votre mémé qui
vous voulez ne serait pas forcément le
même rang du sabot smartphone le
comprends ça c'est cool donc ça
également couplé à l'intelligence
artificielle au gpu turbo vous avez
franchement un rendu qui est très sympa
et qui est très honnêtement ce
smartphone de toute façon les seuls
smartphones d'entrée milieu de gamme
on va pas trop lui en demander on va pas
exigé d'avoir des photos au top de la
performance si vous voulez un photophone
de ouf il va falloir rajouter quelques
euros voire beaucoup 1 euro mais dans
l'absolu se paie smart de mes oeuvres
sont franchement bien moins que je
regretterai un petit peu c'est la caméra
de 8 mégapixels à l'avant je la trouve
pas exceptionnel
dieu pas terrible ça avec le point fort
de ce smartphone en terme de vidéo vous
pouvez filmer jusqu'en full hd 1080p à
60 images par secondes si vous souhaitez
aurélie ça va bravo c'est pas toi qui
fais le briolet qui le fait passer pour
une personne ça ouais bien sûr si c'est
juste pour toi le stress des tricks est
énorme ici pas de quatre cas d'un côté
vous n'aurez pas nécessairement besoin
tout cas c'est pas du tout ce qu on va
rechercher l'a su par contre ça c'est le
point positif comme vous êtes sûrs et mu
vous avez des paramètres vraiment cool
qu'on aime avoir un mode clichés une
option qui va vraiment venir embellir
vos photos nues vous n'allez pas voir
des photos de dingue mais par contre
vous avez quand même pouvoir bluffer vos
amis avec des rendus assez intéressant
alors au final on est sur un smartphone
qui coûte 249 euros voire un peu moins
cher d'ailleurs si vous intéresse je
vous ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description vous pourriez vous faire une
idée du prix est le triple ou jour même
en fonction du site e commerce pour
aller jeter un coup d'oeil on m'a par
contre ce smartphone pour moi c'est un
excellent rapport qualité prix dans sa
catégorie
c'est un smartphone maîtriser l'eau s
étaient prouvées l'autonomie est
excellente maintenant la photo c'est un
peu moyen mais malgré tout il a fallu
faire des choix sur un smartphone à 249
euros vous pouvez pas tout avoir
vous pouvez pas exiger d'avoir le
meilleur photophone une excellente
autonomie beaucoup une performance un
truc de ouf c'est pas possible sinon
smartphone coûtera quand même beaucoup
plus cher et lille ne s'appellerait pas
le paceman donné 19 mai le pépin pro ou
le maïs d'un conte très clairement par
contre pour ce prix là je trouve
vraiment bien je trouve qu'il ya vraie
belle efforts faits au niveau du design
les coins arrondis c'est franchement
très jolie s'était fait dégradé avec
l'aurora bleu ou alors avec le mini
black franchement fait son effet il faut
protéger
mettez une coop derrière sedan les
traces de doigts et les marches compte
n'aime pas dans quelques temps vous
allez franchement à béliveau smartphones
mais au jour d'aujourd'hui début 2019
c'est un bon rapport qualité prix et six
en tout cas vous avez un budget aux
alentours des 250 euros je peux vous
recommander d'aller dessus parce que
huawei a franchement très bien réussi sa
copie et je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez vous est ce que vous aviez le
modèle de l'année dernière est ce que
vous aviez déjà le paceman 2018 et est
ce que ce paceman 2019 vous fait l'oeil
peut vous faire de l'oeil peut vous
intéresser
je vous invite à marquer tout ça en bas
en commentaire vous connaissez vous
marquez tout vous tataï votre clavier
et vous dites ce que vous en pensez et
puis si vous avez d'autres questions je
suis aussi preneur vous pouvez y aller
je vous invite à consulter ma playlist
pour découvrir les autres smartphones du
moment et puis découvrir les smartphones
qui vont arriver parce qu'on en parle
d'ici quelques jours je serai à londres
pour la présentation du nouveau des
nouveaux samsung galaxy s 10 et
également du smartphone pliable de
samsung ça ça va être énorme ici ça va
envoyer du bois
quelques jours après à la conférence de
huawei qui devrait également présenter
son smartphone à écran pliable donc ça
ça va aussi envoyé énormément de bois
mais également la conférence de shlomi
qui va présenter un nouveau smartphone
ont envoyé du bois beaucoup abonnez vous
d'ici là je vous embrasse
soyez sages shop